you know what is up everybody its
prestige Amanda BG here with a
Borderlands the pre-sequel Super Mario
theend easter egg I'm gonna be showing
you what it's like this some of the
secrets inside of the Easter egg and how
to get to it in this video so I hope you
enjoy it and I'll get right into it so
to find this Easter I you're gonna have
to have to take those ribs which is
right before at elysium the place where
you fight the final raid the final boss
in this game so you're gonna head to
take our rigs you can go to Elysium and
work backwards however i think is more
straightforward to go from the top from
the start of it to the end now the area
where you're gonna find easter egg is
kind of far in the end is one of those
elevator portals you can see on the map
and kind of showing you where it is it's
gonna be the elevator that has no
membrane ish barrier at the top of it
now every single one has an orange
hexagonal kind of barrier that if you go
through it will kill you except for a
single one that if you go through you
get teleported to the Easter Egg zone as
you can see that's the one I'm going for
it's right near the end of the area with
the elevators so you're gonna hop onto
the plate and go through it and make
sure it has this black part if it has
the orange part and you try and go up it
you will die and it will really will
serve you any purpose so make sure it's
the black spot and it's really that easy
just go too near the end of Teicher ribs
hop on an elevator and ride and bingo
you're in the Super Mario themed easter
egg now you can see the loop crates and
ammo crates sorry Mario themes the
entire worlds Mario themes however the
enemies that you fight are not gonna be
more into things which I know it's kind
of a letdown you can see I'm I kill
these enemies pretty quickly since I'm a
little bit overleveled I actually heard
about this easter egg a little bit
before I can get to it in my true vault
hunter mode so i decided to go back into
normal vault hunter mode and check it
out and it's a pretty cool place there's
a bunch of warp pipes there's lava
there's the yellow bricks they did a
pretty good job with the music and the
design to keep it where I don't think
they'll have any copyright issues until
they have it too close to the actual
mario theme then they're probably gonna
get a de probably get sued so you're
going to just go through it kill all the
enemies
I think there's about three waves
enemies and once you give a final enemy
you will be let into the next room the
vault room where it has the it has three
good chest I don't pick up any of the
loop since it is not my level and it's
pretty underleveled for me as you can
see I'm low 37 but it's pretty good Lou
also eight there's get a secret part to
it so if you hop up on all the boxes you
see there's a vault symbol hop on all
the boxes and get to the edge which you
can is completely safe it's designed in
game to have it and you can see I looked
at over there where's the it'll lead you
to the loot room so you could get to it
without killing the enemies however
callate kill the enemies since it makes
it easy you can walk through it on the
ground so you're gonna go and you see
this is you'll see the first room which
is where you can get to normally just
walk into it has the three loop chests
and all that good stuff but if you keep
going there's another loop room and you
can only get to this area from going on
the top so if you just go to the first
lieut room and loop the stuff and leave
you're gonna be missing out out on some
potentially really pretty great loop
this doubles your chest loop for the
whole thing so I hope you guys have
enjoyed this hope you guys can go
experience it and find it for yourself
since I thought it was a lot of fun I
appreciate you watching to being at the
video and keep your eye out for my
channel and more Borderlands the
pre-sequel content thanks